Wer einen Blick in die Zukunft werfen will,
der bekommt bei der Consumer Electronics Show
in Las Vegas einen ganz guten Eindruck: Hier
entwerfen die Hersteller die Vision einer
Welt, in der es mit selbstfahrenden Autos
keine Staus
und keine lästige Parkplatzsuche mehr gibt.
Maschinen sollen Krankheiten besser diagnostizieren
als der Mensch und kleine Helfer sollen den Alltag erleichtern.
Zum Beispiel dieser Hundesitter-Roboter:
"Du bist im Büro und dein Hund ist allein
zuhause.
Du kannst den Roboter mit dem Smartphone steuern,
über ihn kannst du mit deinem Hund im Kontakt bleiben, ihn unterhalten."
Roboter werden zu Partnern und Freunden - alles
scheint möglich
im Bereich des sogenannten maschinellen Lernens.
"Ab welchem Zeitpunkt wird die Konversation
mit digitalen Assistenten zur Beziehung?
Über kurz oder lang werden sie in Konversation
mit uns treten, statt wir mit ihnen."
Die Botschaft der Hersteller ist klar: Der
technische Fortschritt soll das Leben unkomplizierter,
länger und produktiver machen.
Dass er auch seine Schattenseiten hat, haben
die Sicherheitslücken bei Computer-Prozessoren
jüngst deutlich gemacht.
Der Optimismus der Branche könne sich als
"naiv" erweisen, warnen Kritiker.